no long-term deal no deal of any kind
for alex smith
in washington as i said earlier this
week from comeback player of the year to
don't come back player next year
that's alex smith 19 million
compensation package
they weren't going to keep in mind miles
we knew this was coming we knew it was
happening
and they need to be respectful they need
to tread lightly he did a lot for the
team last year
helped them get to the playoffs an
inspiring story
and uh all we know is when the disney
movie that inevitably will be made on
the life of alex smith ends it likely
won't end with him
playing for washington it will end with
him playing for someone else and we'll
see where his career goes from here
yeah and look like you said this is
something that we all
expected and it's probably best for both
parties if they move on to separate ways
because i just i don't really think that
alex smith is going to be
the key piece of the puzzle that's going
to make them better
and good enough to then win in the
playoffs and not just
get to the playoffs because they happen
to be the best team in the lowly nfc
east
the the washington should be on
basically the same track almost as
carolina when it comes to trying to find
that
quarterback who is going to be your
franchise guy
that can lead you into the promised land
of whatever this next generation is
of what washington football is going to
be and alex smith i don't think is going
to be that guy i don't know that anybody
would think that alex smith is going to
be that guy that's taking nothing away
from what he was able to accomplish just
by getting back on the field but
i think at this point in his career alex
smith would probably be best served to
be
a backup quarterback somewhere where he
really knows the system
and somewhere where he can mentor guys
like he did with
taylor heinecke who talked really really
highly about him
for the end of the season especially
from that playoff game and everything
that alex smith was able to do to help
him
prepare to start that game and i
honestly played pretty well there so
you know it's it will be interesting to
see where alex smith
ends up because i think wherever he goes
he's going to be able to make an
impact it just might not necessarily be
on the field mike
he's always been very supportive of the
quarterbacks who are on the depth chart
whether they are ahead of him or
behind him san francisco with colin
kaepernick kansas city with patrick
mahomes and homes raved about
what alex smith did in 2017 to get
mahomes ready even though everyone knew
including smith he was going to be gone
after the 2017 season in 2019
the year of recovery and rehab after
that horrendous broken leg and all the
complications
he was there he was working he was
setting the example and he was helping
the young quarterback so
miles it occurred to me a couple of
weeks ago that the bears make the most
sense
for alex smith if he wants to play and
if they're comfortable putting him on
the field i still worry about him like i
used to worry about my son
playing high school football every play
you hold your breath
because it's hard to remove from your
your memory what happened to alex smith
with that broken leg
but uh where do you think he'll end up
i think chicago was certainly a logical
fit i think jacksonville could also be a
logical fit reuniting with urban meyer
after i guess a decade and a half
um after meyer coached him in college i
mean you talk about you know all the
mentorship and stuff i think obviously
we all
expect that jacksonville is going to
take trevor lawrence at number one
overall
well who better to mentor a guy like
trevor lawrence maybe somebody like alex
smith who you can say
yes we know that alex smith has a
history
of being great for young quarterbacks
like that if they can bring in somebody
like an alex smith and say hey man teach
trevor lawrence how to be a pro i think
that could make a lot of sense as well
but
whether it's chicago whether it's
jacksonville he could go back to kansas
city perhaps and be a backup too to
patrick mahomes and
then obviously he knows that offense as
well i think there are some logical fits
for alex smith if he really does want
to extend his career
you know sims and i talked about this
within the past two weeks he made a
great point smith can't really throw the
ball the way that offense needs it now
but
he could fill the matt moore role not
the chat henry roll chad henny back up
alex smith depth chart minimum salary a
little bit more than that just to just
to help patrick mahomes
get to the next level a little
self-scouting kind of a transition to
coaching maybe
for alex smith but i think he still has
a lot to offer
to a team wherever he ends up and uh
he'll be a great
supporter and and somebody who
if if you need him on the field you put
him on the field i'm not ready to rule
out a starting job for alex smith but
i think the bears would have to exhaust
plenty of other options
before they would go with alex smith hi
i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports